there's a um a stat out there that they
says that they say after a certain
amount of money i'm going to ask you
i'm going to ask the audience i'm going
to ask you guys after you hit a certain
number of income
that
happiness doesn't grow but you know
exponentially meaning there's a certain
number that if you hit that number you
can you're going to be happy meaning if
you're broke and you're making you know
minimum wage and you got two kids like
you can't be happy that's that's tough
what do you think the number is you want
to go first nancy
i want to say it like assuming that
you're alone exactly oh okay
just i'm just in general there's a and i
actually think the number is a little
bit higher that's is my opinion but
there's stats out there that show this
is the number where people are happy
just assume it's a person or even with
the even with kids whatever this is what
the number allegedly like an annual
salary you're saying exactly annual
salary google this put it up there
don't show just say
the amount of money that makes you happy
and then i'll i'll give the
say about 65. 65. yeah okay 65.
interesting any reason that you put pick
that number
um i think it covers the essentials you
need and
still room to save things like that like
you're obviously not balling out every
weekend but it also keeps you humble so
like know when you can like cut back on
things stay humble stay foolish i like
it jenny valdez the jenny valdez in la
casa latino
oh my god jenny what is the number
that we're talking about that actually
makes people happy what do you think the
number is she said 65 grand what do you
think
the average person yeah um
that makes you i would say 50. 50.
that's your number so we got 50 and we
got 65. and i have a lot of numbers from
the audience too oh what are they saying
i love that nancy's managing the
audience sure let me see um jason says
72 000. martin says 120 000.
miss cassandra aguilar says 500 000.
okay cassandra flip this let me see
what's going on right there
okay
okay nice all right flip it uh eric you
want to reveal this number real quick
the amount of money that makes people
happy
here it is
globally we find this at it that
oh
here we go globally we find that the
what is that
satisfaction occurs at 95 000 for life
valuation and 60 to 75 000 for emotional
well-being the study shows uh however
the study also found that the ideal
income for life satisfaction in north
america is 105 000 as reported by inc
that number has changed how about this
the how much money does it take before
plateauing go down one more boom what's
that number right there
because then the number that i have seen
is 75 000. let's see what this says here
a decade ago a study out of princeton
university made headlines for showing
that the income level of 75 000 per
household was the sweet spot for
happiness now clearly with inflation
right now that's bumped up to almost a
105 grand but basically they've put a
number to happiness right now so 75
grand was the number and apparently
that's over a hundred grand right now
per household is like both of their
incomes are just one income that's what
household means or you could be a single
dude okay like my household income
understood 100 right
um anyway so that's that's it you ask
what the best investment is um
but one of the worst investments don't
get it twisted just because your cars
are a little bit more expensive these
days this bubble is going to burst
people are going to get back to work
people you know the supply chain is
going to get cut chips are going to get
made taiwan is the number one
country that produces microchips they're
also called semiconductors and boom next
thing you know you think you're going to
invest in a car and make some money
crash so anyway um that is the car story
we factored in a little bit of happiness
right there we talked about investing
yourself i think that was a great topic
[Music]